opel kommt es heute ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen essens video
leute ich bin letztens ich war letzten
halt warten wir heute zum beispiel haben
wir sonntag die sind ja ein bisschen
nach videos produzieren weil ich nächste
woche weg bin
und gestern aber auch was gedreht und
ich habe dann bei lieferando pizza
bestellt oder so mir ist aufgefallen
es gibt so 234 leben die haben einfach 0
bewertungen also gar keine und lassen
erkennen setzen ich hab ja vor allem
weil ja oder so relativ freundlich so
videos gemacht ich teste das
schlechteste note 2 restaurant burger
restaurant in meiner stadt um so aber
bleibt das hat mich dann auf die idee
gebracht so was mal wieder so ein
bisschen neu aufleben zu lassen gleich
markt und halt diese restaurants zu
testen die halt absolut keine
bewertungen haben um dann der erste zu
sein da die werden kann so cool weil
wenn ihr der bewertung haben die gut ist
kriegen die halle auch mehr kunden und
werden sinne bewertung haben wir
schlecht ist den sie auch weniger kunden
wobei sich das stark wundert wie hier in
köln bei lieferando in der pizzeria gar
keine bewertung haben kann irgendwie ein
bisschen strange also mal schauen ob da
überhaupt eben was ankommt gut also ich
will eigentlich gar nicht lange drum rum
da war ich zeige euch das ganze mag und
ich habe gerade schon mal geschaut wir
haben zur auswahl
also wir haben gerade wirklich 20 uhr
und wir wollen weiter was essen wir
haben zur auswahl pizza und burger das
sind wirklich beides läden die haben 0
bewertungen was wärst du also juli pizza
wirtschaft also material das ich mal
kurz schauen wo ist das was ich meine
genau pizzaservice bambino zb
mindestbestellwerte 09 euro da steht so
ein neuer button dran und die brauchen
sogar noch eine halbe stunde das an dem
sonntag abend um diese uhrzeit irgendwie
vertraue ich der ganzen sache nicht so
und das erste was kommt es natürlich
currywurst wer kennt es nicht
pizzaservice bambino erstmal der
currywurst egal wir haben nur
mindestbestellwert von 9 euro was
möchten haben pizza salami
pizza salami ok und weitere 25 extras
möchte 26 cm wahrscheinlich ja okay und
dazu dann noch schinken kostet hier und
du bist mir in bern kopf schon mal
sieben euro 40 okay und ich würde dann
einfach mal sagen ich nehme dann nudeln
oder oder irgendwie sowas hier pasta
spaghetti oder war schon mal vielleicht
im jahr was anderes hier gibt es noch
kartoffelauflauf das ist das denn für
eine pizzeria
es ist ganz komisch gyros und currywurst
bad jetzt thailändische spezialitäten
was und das hat noch gar keine
bewertungen chinesisch schweiz
die haben ja alles nur aus interesse der
bürger haben sie nicht überrissen rollos
junge hier jetzt ja alles so war es
jetzt schon
ich habe etwas gefunden was mich
interessiert und zwar eine kartoffel
brocken die pfanne mit brokkoli tomaten
und gorgonzola das ist ja nichts was man
sich normalerweise beim lieferservice
gestellt ok also ich soll ja schon dass
man sich wirklich gestellt tschuldigung
alles ja ja dann bleibt mir nichts
anderes übrig als aber das wär doch mal
interessant kommen dann nehme ich hier
einfach mal ich mag den rest an ich will
ja auch etwas nehmen was sie gerne mag
das hier spaghetti royal mit auberginen
champignons knoblauch und tomate
sahnesoße kommunen schon teuer sind wir
bei 17 euro wir brauchen wir ja auch
eigentlich nicht oder das selbst nur
gucken dann wären wir wahrscheinlich
ganz runter und gehört habe auf jeden
fall schon habe ich gerade gelesen
spaghetti eis aber das ist ja alles
fertig das ja aber ich möchte das haben
was möchte man da von ok juni möchte
noch ein spaghetti 1 gut wenn sonst
nichts ist und ich wollte schon oben
noch mal ganz kurz zeigen 0 bewertungen
ja also ich mich auch nicht das ist
alles live
ich bin gespannt habe stellen wollen
okay ich habe stellt liefert zählt
ungefähr 30 minuten surfen waren halt
macht ich bin echt gespannt
und dann gibt es die erste bewertung von
mir und wie gesagt es gibt auch noch
einen burger an der keine bewertungen
dass man dann auch noch wobei ich das
dann auch schon echt kritisch in der
2000 jahre später vergessen ist das ist
glaube ich aus dem aldi oder so nach
außen weißt du dass du überall krieg
aufheben
deshalb 320 mit dem supermarkt kostet
ganzer tag und ein euro neue leute oder
so ich übers blech
das ist eine frechheit aber in der tat
ich weiß gar nicht ob das wirklich jetzt
ja das ist eine pizzeria da muss ja sein
das wollte ich auch immer schon mal in
meinem leben machen
der erste lieferant wörter seien von dem
restaurant
also das ist jetzt hier das essen was 25
euro bestellt waren
ich würde sagen dass man hier mit anfang
und zu schauen ob das wirklich das ist
was ich denke für 23 kann man sich doch
auch da denkt man so vielleicht machen
die das selber oder machen da irgendwie
eine halbwegs gut aussehende kreationen
aus oder
und dann kommt ein paar 23
wir fanden fünf stellen an einstellen es
schon mal abzug dafür aber trotzdem
julia fiedler ich muss mal kurz ins
kühlfach nein nicht das erste mal so
soll ich mit der pizza weiter machen wir
mit den nudeln edelmetall ist doppelt in
der kiste
ene mene meck
also ich guck mal drauf und das ist ja
deine tipps dann kann nicht direkt sagen
ob die gut aussieht oder halt auch nicht
[Musik]
also ich bin nicht so ein fan von dieser
name ist finken pizzen gleich war es
sieht jetzt nicht schlimm aus aber ich
habe auch schon deutlich schönere
gesehen was dazu oder aussagen die
zuschauer geht das ja es hat eine
standard liefert also ich denke die wir
doch durchschnittlich schmecken
also das ist ja deiner die kannst du
gleich mal probieren oder soll ich auch
ein stück probieren
ich probiere auch nicht okay ich habe
mal kurz im wasser und an stücken alter
die ist ja fertig als fett das fett rief
da einfach nur förmlich heraus ich sag
mal so ist nicht meins kann aber auch
daran liegen weil ich so was generell
nicht so gerne mag wird so schenken
drauf aber es schmeckt echt nicht gut
aber wir haben auch die nun endlich
einmal problem du kannst du weißt ja
meine lieblings pizza haben dann kannst
du es schmeckt wie ganz normalen etat
pizza komplett den schritt ich okay
absolut in ordnung ist absolut in
ordnung also ich würde das jetzt nicht
aufessen sag mal so ich find's ok ich
finde es absolut gut
es gibt viel schlechter würde ich mal
sagen gibt es hier keinen stern ab sucht
oder es komplett ok immer noch bei 4
sternen
und dann haben wir jetzt noch die nudeln
was war das noch mal mit champignons
tomaten sahnesoße also hier haben wir
nudeln mit also die pilze finde ich
sehen ist nicht appetitlich aus muss ich
sagen dass auch jetzt mit riechen tut es
eigentlich ganz gut aber erinnert mich
ein bisschen an sondern so eine
asiatische logischerweise aber sieht
dies auch nicht fertig gemacht aus also
es sind reingelegt aus angst dass sie
irgendwie als aufsatz für fünf monate in
der kühltruhe liegt also das ist
durchgemacht mir ja gut das erwarte ich
auch wenn ich dafür acht euro bezahlen
[Musik]
also wie nudeln sind recht gut
muss ich sagen ist auch noch sehr heiß
der bahn geblieben
aber man muss ich gleich noch mal
probieren
[Musik]
also mir persönlich nicht gut jetzt
probiere ich mal hier noch ein
champignon ich hätte es nicht gedacht
und liefert auch die fast eine halbe
stunde also lieferungen eigentlich fünf
sterne essen
der würde ich jetzt keine vier stände
geben aber es liegt glaube ich auch in
meinem eigenen geschmack weißt du und du
hast du bestellt das kriegt von mir fünf
sterne weil du sagst du freak 4
dann passt es ja auch noch ein ja gut
das heißt es halt ein bisschen teuer
genauere gewesen das eis ist diese
vorstellung aber dann lass mich mal kurz
hier die bewerbungsschreiben für die den
neuen burger laden den ich meine er
heißt bauer bürger müssen wir halt echt
ok also hier kann ich jetzt einnehmen
wie zufrieden warst du mit deiner
bestellung was hat mal gesagt
lieferungen fünf sterne und essen hier
craft solche monster zu schreiben wie
immer unter meinem ganzen youtube-videos
okay sagt sehr gut soll jetzt bewertet
ich bin der erste und eventuell dass ich
dann wieder bei sonst können leute halt
mein wundert euch nicht leicht soviel
dazu war ganz interessant ich glaube er
den burger lagen könnte es noch
interessanter werden weil das halt
irgendwie dann noch risiko risikoreicher
ist trotzdem hoffe ich es hat euch
gefallen daumen nach oben weitere ideen
für essens wie du es wie immer gerne in
die kommentare
das war es voll rein
[Musik]